Oi
[Aplausos]
bom dia boa tarde boa noite meu nome é
Gustavo Lucas mais conhecido como Largo
degusta tenho 19 anos nascido e criado
na Baixada Fluminense do Rio de Janeiro
e vou contar para vocês um pouquinho da
minha história
a Palhada eu
escrevi aqui mais ou menos uma poesia Eu
acho que eu tô sentido do com que eu
vivo com que eu faço hoje em dia e vou
contar aqui para você ver
há mais ou menos assim começa assim
desde pequeno prestando com o meu de uma
vida muito tempo quase me pergunte se
sou bom para te mostrar minha caminhada
é longa história o gravando no
guarda-roupa ficar na minha memória mas
eu essencial para chegar até aqui falar
que sou do game Não é piada para você
rir pode me dando oportunidade eu
esperando a minha usada para o Paraná
metade quem parou os olhos Pega a visão
acredita que esse tronco dentro do seu
coração né não vou começar como que sim
como eu vou usar sem medo de perder só
depende de você ela só depende de você é
que você sabe qual caminho seguir nunca
pare não pensem que sair mesmo dando
errado você vai conseguir ontem nem
acreditei eu estou aqui
acho que minha paixão e minha
minha vontade de fazer rap veio em 2017
comecei a rimar na rua com meus amigos
Messiah fazendo fiz tarde assistindo
batalha de Lima e quando eu fui ver eu
tava incluído eu não vi
lá em casa as coisas estão muito a
música era todo dia a minha mãe o gênero
mínimo escutando outro gênero então a
música Era muito presente na minha casa
é só que em 2017 eu comecei a batalhar
com batalha em escolas batalhei em roda
de rima perto da minha comunidade Só que
lá na profissional
então o Onix 2017 Foi macumba um
aprendizado para mim ao tudo quando
chegou em 2018 eu comecei a focar mais e
querer escrever uma letra que ele botar
para frente só que eu não conseguia
estúdio não conseguia os recursos
necessários para gravar um som não
conseguia um equipamento um fone algo do
tipo Então chegou
então chegou uma final do ano de 2018 eu
batalhando fazendo batalha de rima
cheguei fui em Itaguaí conhecer um
parceiro E
arrumei um estúdio gravando a primeira
música então fui gravar minha primeira
música
Ela saiu no YouTube pela quantidade de
viu que tinha já tava ótimo o ano de
2018 passou não sei minha primeira
música fiquei felizão
até então e eu não consegui gravar minha
música no estúdio ou quando grava em
casa qualidade era um pouco ruim porque
eu não tinha um microfone como eu disse
eu não tinha um recurso necessário então
eu e meus amigos dava um jeito para
tentar gravar eu comecei a gravar minha
música dentro do armário dentro de um
guarda-roupa a gente abre o armário abre
as duas portas e abrir a roupa no meio
voltava o microfone no meio começava a
cantar ou ali ou numa Palio que meu
amigo tinha e foi assim que a gente
começou editando a música pelo celular
mesmo eu tentando fazer alguma coisa
pegar um kit do computador pegar um bit
free algo do tipo e até então o gel pode
entrar em contato comigo eu não tinha
nenhum equipamento não tinha um estúdio
certo para aí eu não tinha um lá para
gravar minhas músicas e aí hoje ela foi
me deu oportunidade de um estúdio muito
bravo no Rio de Janeiro em graças a Deus
tive essa oportunidade de gravar no
primeira música profissionalmente Na
época eu tava precisando até de um de um
dinheiro em casa não lembro que o que
que você quer se era para um gás o Ceará
com a mistura Eu só fui construindo a
intenção de eu quero a música de
realizar meu sonho não sabia que a
receber algo em troca porque eu também
nem queria né eu tinha vergonha de falar
com as pessoas tipo o quê que eu sentia
o quê que eu falava o saco aí chegou o
convite do vinho até São Paulo conversar
com a rapaziada trocar uma ideia
propagada também apresentar o melhor
projeto sobre a música E aí a gente
tocou uma ideia eu cheguei com o
vergonha não fala para ninguém
era time dão trocar umas ideia lá o
pegar chegou em mim e falou todo o
projeto explicou tudo como é que seria
se eu ia continuar fazendo minhas
músicas do mesmo jeito ou não e ele me
apresentou o projeto com a maneira de
juntar o treco e o game porque
não era um bagulho que a gente envia
tanto e fez essa junção aí eu aí de
cabeça vê uma oportunidade falei vou
embora e não é porque eu não conhecia
mano jeito nenhum eu não tinha ideia do
mundo do esporte
por rapaziada dos Games que tipo ela é
sério mesmo que o bagulho muda a vida
acho que o bagulho tipo dá oportunidade
para rapaziada que em troca eu não achei
a solução
mas eu não podia perder oportunidade né
pai então eu cheguei e falei favor eu
conheço você pa um tipo na realmente não
mentir porque logo assim que eu falei
para ela que eu conhecia eu comecei a
pesquisar todos os pensadores ver que
tem sozinho ver com o jogo ele jogava o
que eles escutavam e eu vi que ele
estava começando a escutar muito essa
música que central do projeto que era
juntar o tep com game eu caí de cabeça
que eu sabia que ia dar bom o meu estilo
de música Trocar a outra eu sempre fui
te contar mais diversas o que eu passei
passaram só que tipo assim hoje em dia é
o canto o que que eu passei o que que
meus amigos passaram o que que tá
fazendo passou para chegar até aqui que
não foi fácil mas tô ligado como é que é
tudo tem um percurso tudo tem um caminho
tem que treinar uma caminhada ainda para
você chegar no lugar onde você quer
então hoje em dia num canto o que que a
Rapaziada vive nos campeonatos Branca
porque rapaz Serra da Vivi e que não pra
alguma coisa que fazer uma vivência
Ah
então é por aí é por é assim o mundo tá
bem graças a Deus hoje em dia na minha
casa mano sem sair de casa a gente eu tô
tendo - equipamentos em casa eu posso
gravar não me preocupo de ir no estúdio
é porque mano jogo é coisa séria o Mundo
dos Games é coisa séria não é só um
joguinho não é só uma brincadeira a
gente não tá ali se divertindo só Será
que a gente tá fazendo nossa profissão
então eu espero humano que se você tem
esse foco de um dia ser um game ou seus
times ou trabalhar e qualquer área mano
não precisa ser necessariamente não é
frente pode ser a música agora também
cantar sobre games ou algo relacionado
mano confira vai dar certo corra atrás
confio em você mesmo e é praticamente
isso se o final muito obrigado a toda a
minha família minha mãe principalmente
que foi o Pilar para chegar até aqui
estamos juntos